AI is an abbreviation for artificial
intelligence and the goal of AI is to
meet or exceed human intelligence in the
form of technology. This means that our
computers would be able to learn, infer,
and reason based on input that we
provide. This is obviously not a new
idea. We've been working on concepts of
AI for a number of decades. And of
course, you see AI mentioned in numerous
science fiction stories. But now, of
course, AI has become much more
prevalent. We have new tools that allow
us to create new content such as text,
audio, and video by simply asking a
computer to create it.
And very quickly, we have seen AI become
integrated into most applications that
we use every day. For example, if you
perform a search on a popular search
engine, you may find not only your
search results, but also a summary of
those results that was created using
artificial intelligence. The goal is to
take information that normally you would
need to find across multiple sites and
present all of that information to you
as one single AI summary. We've also
seen AI in our email clients and on our
mobile devices. Instead of having to
read through a long email, you can read
an AI summary that explains the
information that was contained in that
message. And as you've probably seen in
graphics editors, you can use generative
AI to fill in or remove information from
an image by simply highlighting it on
the screen and asking the AI to remove
it. We've also seen artificial
intelligence engines that allow you to
input a description of what you'd like
an image to be and the AI will create
that image on the screen.
We've seen a number of different uses of
AI that we could put into the category
of appropriate AI use. For example,
there may be extremely large data
repositories that we would like AI to be
able to sift through and provide us with
a summary of that information. For
example, there's AI that can look
through terabytes and terabytes of log
files in an organization and find
potential security issues that may be
hidden in all of these different logs.
This would certainly be timeconuming and
difficult for a human to do, which makes
it perfect for AI. We've also started
integrating AI into our scripting and
our automation so that AI can make
decisions on what to do when a certain
situation occurs. Being able to do this
without human intervention means that we
can spend our time doing something else.
We're also seeing AI integrated more
into health care. For example, AI can
take the output from an MRI scanner and
evaluate that to see if there may be
something that would be concerning. We
might also have AI go through healthcare
records and determine if anyone is
receiving multiple drugs that might have
negative interactions. This means the
health care professionals can work with
us at a human level and have AI take
care of everything at a digital level.
And if you're watching this video on
YouTube, you may be getting realtime
language translation thanks to the AI
that's built into our new communications
apps.
But of course, there are downsides to
any technology and AI has been used for
things that may not be as appropriate.
For example, we've seen AI used for
fraud. AI can impersonate a real person
and even create video of that person,
something we refer to as a deep fake.
We've also seen application code that's
created with AI without any knowledge of
what the application is actually doing.
Or perhaps someone is using AI to create
an image and taking credit for that
image creation. And we've seen AI used
in schools and colleges to plagiarize
works. Students are using AI to
summarize existing works, but they're
not citing AI in that summary.
One of the challenges we have when
working with AI is that it can sometimes
have a bias. The AI only knows the
information that we're feeding into it
and it has a predefined set of
algorithms on how to manage that data.
And sometimes AI can make the wrong
conclusions based on this combination of
data and algorithms. For example, we may
be feeding AI a very large data set
associated with health care in the
United States, but inside of that data
set, we may have under represented
statistics for a particular ethnic group
or particular gender group. In this
case, AI could potentially create
conclusions that are biased one way or
the other. We're obviously not trying to
create bias as part of this AI analysis.
So we have to make sure that we create
an AI algorithm that doesn't build bias
when we have these large data sets. A
good example of this is what Amazon
found when they took 10 years of
submitted résumés and put them into an
AI engine. This grouping of résumés had
a number of terms such as executed and
captured as part of the résé text. The
artificial intelligence engine tended to
pick résumés that had those terms as
part of the resume itself. What we found
is that those terms were more often used
when it was a male submitting a resume
versus a female and therefore the AI
created a bias towards male résumés.
Obviously, Amazon chose not to use this
AI algorithm for their resume research.
There's also occasions where AI can
completely misrepresent the data that it
was provided. You can think of this as a
confidently incorrect AI where it really
knows the answer but the answer is
completely wrong. For example, let's say
that we've told the AI that any picture
containing a snout, a tail, and four
legs is a dog. Then we provide the AI
with a picture of a cloud and the cloud
appears to have a nose, a tail, and four
legs. Therefore, the cloud is obviously
a real dog. This is obviously a
simplified way to describe an AI
hallucination, but this is what tends to
occur when we have this type of data
misinterpretation. These are also not
very unusual to find, and you may have
seen an AI hallucination when performing
your own tests with an AI engine. A
practical example of an AI hallucination
was when Google and Microsoft announced
their new AI technologies. Google
announced Google Bard. This is now
Google Gemini. and Microsoft introduced
Microsoft Bing Chat. Both of these
engines provided a summary of some
articles that had completely wrong
information inside of them.
Unfortunately, this hallucination was in
the announcement that Google made
regarding their new AI engine. This AI
engine took an input that said, "What
new discoveries from the James Web Space
Telescope can I tell my 9-year-old
about?" And then it gave a number of
bullets that you could use to help
describe the James Webb Space Telescope
and its findings. Unfortunately, one of
these findings was that the James Webb
Space Telescope took the very first
picture of a planet outside of our own
solar system. Bruce Macintosh replied to
this and said, "Speaking as someone who
imaged an exoplanet 14 years before the
JW Space Telescope was launched, it
feels like you should find a better
example." This points out that even the
best AI engines can suffer from an AI
hallucination.
Behind the scenes, artificial
intelligence is creating a conclusion
using a model that is provided. And
sometimes it makes the wrong conclusion
based on the model that it was given.
And researchers will often perform tests
of an AI engine to see how accurate it
might be. They will get predictions from
the AI and then they will compare those
predictions to known test data. One of
these accuracy tests was done by
originality.ai. They did an AI
fact-checking accuracy study in August
of 2024, and you can read through the
study yourself at the URL that you see
here. They evaluated their own AI and a
number of other AIs that were currently
available. The originality.ai
engine got a 72.3%
accuracy. GPT4 got a 64.9%
accuracy rating and GPT3.5 got a 58.6.
six accuracy rating. As you can see, our
current iterations of AI are far from
perfect and in some cases fall well
under what most people think AI is able
to do.
There's been a lot of work made on both
public AIs and private AIs. A public AI
would be one that is publicly available
on the internet. Things like ChatGpt or
Google Gemini are good examples of a
public AI. But some companies are
creating their own AI engines and these
would be engines that are private to
that organization. These would commonly
have proprietary company data and the
organization has complete control over
the modeling used for that artificial
intelligence engine. The decision on
whether you use a public AI or a private
AI may be based on data security.
Whenever you put information into an AI
engine, there is a possibility that that
data could be retrieved. And if that
data is sensitive or contains private
information, you could be putting that
information available for anyone on the
internet to see. We've also seen cases
where an AI was able to provide
passwords, encryption keys, certificate
details, and other sensitive
information. Of course, if you're
running a private AI, only people within
that organization have access to that
proprietary data, and therefore, it
limits the scope of any type of breach.
There's also quite a big difference
between a public AI and a private AI
when it comes to how much data they're
able to evaluate. Obviously, a private
AI is only going to have data from a
single entity, but a public AI is
collecting data from everybody who's on
the internet. In those cases, it may be
that your public AI is more accurate
than the private AI because the public
AI has access to so much more data. But
it is that large amount of data that
does create concerns about privacy. Some
of that information that's being stored
by a public AI is information about you.
The AI knows where you live. It might
even know your previous addresses, has
information about your habits and things
that you do on the internet, and it may
have details about any memberships and
groups that you belong to. Let's say
you're applying for a job. What type of
summary would the AI create of you and
what would be contained within your
profile?